foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello hello
hi
everybody's very chatty today
which I will I'll take all the energy
from you guys that I can get because I
am running on fumes right now
I was at a band competition up from 5 30
a.m to about 2 A.M this morning so just
give me all the energy give me the
energy I'll take it
welcome to the table my name is Karen I
am so glad you're here it's good to see
your faces I know it's not always easy
getting here at five o'clock on a Sunday
so good job you did it you are here you
can relax
ah arrive
I have a couple of announcements and
ways to get connected here at the table
first of all also Welcome to our online
attenders the table isn't just the
people in here we also have people who
Faithfully watch online every week can
you guys just maybe wave like wave
behind you cameras back here we'll pick
it up yeah welcome online people
all right announcements
first of all very very important we have
a conference coming up called
centerpiece
yes centerpiece is happening this coming
Thursday Friday and Saturday at Wilshire
Baptist Church in Dallas it is an
amazing conference I got to attend
virtually was it last year the year
before whenever they did it last and I
was blown away it was incredible we have
these cards that have information as far
as when the conferences how to register
for it you just have a few more days to
sign up these will be out out that back
door by the little little tiny wooden
box out there you can grab one of these
there's plenty of them so grab one for
yourself grab one for family friends
anybody you think that might benefit
from a conference that's all about
navigating faith and sexuality okay it's
an important topic it's one that applies
to everyone and the people that are
running this conference are incredible
they're really good friends at the table
a lot of us from the table will be there
Brett's going to be facilitating a
breakout session Marissa back there is
heading is working with a bunch of
volunteers
I'll be there we have some of our
worship team leading worship at the
centerpiece conference so it is a family
affair and we hope that you will be
there as well it's going to be a great
great time so again grab a card on your
way out
secondly we have some baptism classes
coming up next month November 13th and
20th those are both Sundays so
immediately following the service you
can meet with Brett he'll tell you all
about baptism if you want to know more
about it like
what is baptism why should I get
baptized I got baptized as a kid should
I get baptized again like you can have
those conversations in these classes and
then we are planning to do a baptism
event towards the beginning of next year
so we'll have those two opportunities to
do classes and then the event in
sometime in January I promise it won't
be too cold for those of you that are
getting baptized but if you're
interested we would love to have you be
part of those we'll be giving you more
information for how to sign up later
just wanted to put those dates November
13th and 20th in your ear so you can
save the dates in your calendar for that
I think that's it I know we have the
table t-shirts that are in so if you
ordered a t-shirt see Maggie she's got
those for you tonight yay
all right how about if we take a moment
to just Center ourselves
truly be here now
and prepare our hearts for worship So
Close Your Eyes bow your heads
God
we take a breath and we take a pause and
just remember why we're here
Jesus we Center on you we remember that
you are the source of peace
and love and goodness and patience
so God help us to open our ears and our
hearts tonight for whatever you have for
us thank you for this community
full of energy full of people that
reflect your image God
I am so grateful for this community
so God may we celebrate you tonight may
we celebrate each other tonight
remembering your faithfulness and that
each one of us are loved far more than
we can ever imagine God help us to
Center on that tonight to truly believe
it
to trust you at greater levels
and to just be connected to those around
us and to you God tonight in Jesus name
I pray amen
thanks Karen do you guys want to stand
with us if you'd like we're going to get
started with our worship and
um yeah I hope that you will feel the
freedom I feel like music is one of
those powerful tools that can connect
people in a room even that have never
met each other you know you go to a
concert and you don't know the people
around you by the end of it it feels
like some kind of communal experience
just happened where you're all like
totally in on something so I hope
tonight as we're singing even the words
that we're saying would connect us back
with each other and with this source of
love this source of creativity and
beauty and forgiveness and Grace so
um yeah y'all enter in with us
[Music]
thank you
I love you Lord for you have to live in
me
I love you Lord
[Music]
my
soul from death my feet from stumbling I
will walk in the land of the living
[Music]
thank you
I love you Lord
me
I love you Lord for you have delivered
my soul from my feet from stumbling
in the land
believe
foreign
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
yeah thank you guys y'all sound so great
kiddos y'all are dismissed to go to your
classroom and if y'all would use this
store right here today because we're um
trying to keep out of that room for
Pleasant Valley this week thank you
we're gonna keep on flowing into into
the prayers of the people right now and
Noel is going to lead that for us so you
guys can follow her and I will read that
all aloud and if you're online feel free
to leave a comment and we will share
that as well so that everyone can hear
foreign
Texas and for every city and community
and all of those who live in them we
pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and will to conserve
it
pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the Widow and the orphan for the
injured and the suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
in situations up to you
[Music]
foreign
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
and I've carried about
foreign
[Music]
done with the hiding no reasons
you so much day Edition
[Music]
your son for me Redemption
the price for my heart
and I don't ever
contacts
for that kind of love I don't understand
I can't comprehend
[Music]
I'll fall into place
spinning
your sides long before
my first
breath running into your
[Music]
s
deep in my chest with Mercy is
now I run to the father I fall into
Grace I'm done with the hiding the
reasons
[Music]
again and again again and again and
again
[Music]
thank you Jesus
that coming back to you isn't like
someone returning to shame but it's
someone finding freedom
finding forgiveness
thank you that you're a gracious God
and that you're always calling us to
more
you're always calling us deeper
to become more like you
and to become the best versions of
ourself
[Music]
foreign
I just wanna speak the name of Jesus
till every dark addiction starts to
break
[Music]
[Applause]
shine through the Shadows
I just wanna speak the name of Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
I speak Jesus
my name is power
your name is healing
your name is
[Music]
shout Jesus from the mountains
Jesus in the streets
Jesus in the Darkness
every enemy
Jesus for my family I speak the Holy
Name Jesus
[Music]
from the mountains
Jesus in the Darkness
[Music]
the enemy
enemy and Jesus
[Music]
name is power
your name is healing
make every song
[Music]
your name is
you
[Music]
I just want to speak the name of Jesus
over every heart and every mind
cause I know there is
I speak to you
shout Jesus from the mountains
but Jesus in the streets and Jesus in
the darkness over every enemy
Jesus for my family I speak the Holy
Name of Jesus
foreign
[Music]
to me
God is so good
is
so good
he's so good
to please
yes you are good to us
and hold our chaos
chaos struggle
you are light Breaking Through The
Darkness
you are healing in our pain
you are the hand reaching out and
pulling us forward
[Music]
beyond the things that hold us back
beyond our past
[Music]
Beyond even our expectations of the
future that are untrue
are hopeless
[Music]
or negative you are The Voice of Truth
you are the voice of love
would we hang on to it in the middle of
the storm would it be our anchor would
it be our Center Point
would it be the thing we come back to
again and again and again would we run
to our father who's full of grace
full of new beginnings and making a new
creation out of us
to your good work in our lives and God
would we be the first ones to offer it
to this world
would we be the first ones to speak that
truth over someone else's Darkness
to offer friendship over someone else
who is lonely
[Music]
to offer Grace to our enemies who have
wronged us
foreign make us people of change
of transformation
[Music]
people like you
we love you God and we're grateful for
this time together we're grateful for
this community
[Music]
continue to do your work here in Jesus
name we all said amen
you guys for worshiping with us Brett's
going to get started on the message in a
minute but could you guys turn to the
people around you welcome them greet
them make them feel at home
good evening grace and peace
my name is Brett and uh I'm gonna pass
through here and it is so so good to be
with all of you and
um that I mean getting a little feedback
let me scoot back we've adjusted our
speakers so we've noticed the feedbacks
that's why I'm I'm kind of up on the
stage tonight
um
so it's so good to be with all of you in
that as always includes those joining us
online so glad to have you with us and
anyone here who is just new to the table
um we're so glad to have you with us and
um you know Jesus was so incredibly
hospitable and uh just welcoming and we
seek to live out that same that same
kind of welcome so just know if you're
here and you're new we're really glad
that you're with us so um we are
beginning a new series tonight so
another good reason if you're if you're
new with us this is a great night to be
here
um so the the title of the series is
stranger things
foreign you you know you've seen the
Netflix hit
um so I I must admit we won't be talking
about the upside down or Dungeons and
Dragons uh sorry to disappoint
um instead the the subtitle of the
series is when the Bible gets weird
and
um you know I mean if you read the Bible
you've probably come across those
moments where the eyebrows go up
you know sort of uh it's like oh oh oh
interesting I didn't I didn't know that
was in there and um and so we're gonna
take four weeks and just look at some of
those kind of stories
um you know I mean week three will be
that will be one that's kind of intense
like where it's sort of like horrifying
like oh bad you know this one's it's not
so much like horrified it's more just
weird you know and that's the theme of
the series right when the Bible gets
just strange a little bit and um so the
uh kind of with that in mind
um the title of the message specific to
tonight is donkeys
fears and spirituality gone wrong
and some of you might have a few guesses
as to where we're going
um so this is a story it is it's a bit
obscure uh probably not known to a
number of you
if you do know it as we'll kind of get
into it's for a weird little portion of
it and uh which we'll touch on but it
won't really be like the point
um
so this this story this is found um in
the Book of Numbers it's kind of a long
rambling story numbers chapters 22 23 24
and then it jumps uh to chapter 31. and
so it's uh I mean it's a it's a strange
one so to give some background to this
basically uh the Israelites God's people
they have journeyed out of Egypt in
remarkable fashion you'll recall Moses
and the party of the Red Sea and you
know let my people go all that so uh
they've exited Egypt they've kind of
journeyed to the desert they've fought a
few battles and they're um somewhat
Infamous now in the region uh and people
are starting to
um kind of live in fear of them because
they're like or your people and they're
afraid of being conquered and such so
basically they've encamped on the nation
of Moab uh on their kind of doorstep
they haven't invaded but they're just
kind of camping out there enough that
the king of Moab his name is baylock uh
he he was nervous nervous as a cat he's
like oh gosh we have something uh and he
felt some uh that he needed like
spiritual power that it wasn't enough to
just get some more you know Spears and
swords or whatever he needed some sort
of spiritual power so what he does is he
sends emissaries uh and now you can tell
by the distance he sends them that this
was a special person he sends emissaries
350 miles away
to speak with this what do you call him
kind of a a fear a um Prophet a a
someone who kind of has this certain
spiritual power
um and his name is Balaam and so 350
miles I mean that's the journey even
today in a car but you can imagine back
you know when you're traveling by foot
or by camel this you know this Balaam he
had quite the reputation and the reason
he um was willing to kind of seek out
specifically Balaam and not go to some
local uh spiritual Guru or whatever is
uh because they only had this reputation
that he was able to um like be very in
tune with God receive words from God and
speak both blessings and curses over not
just like individuals but entire peoples
and people groups and so of course
baylock became Moab he's like ah this is
what I need I need this Balaam character
um now it's kind of interesting so
basically he sends these emissaries uh
Balaam like you might I don't know the
way I've described him you might think
of him as this sort of uh well and we'll
get into based on other biblical texts
he's really seen as this sort of devious
um evil character it's strange though in
the beginning here all this these early
chapters he really doesn't come across
like that at all I mean for one thing
the emissaries come to him and like hey
would you come with us we're going to
pay you a lot of money he's like
Consulting uh to you know curse these
people and he turns them down he's like
no the Lord told me not to go
and they're like would you reconsider
he's like nope so they leave they come
back they're like please and then this
time he like goes again to God like hey
should I go with him this time the
Lord's like yes
so he's like okay so then he's gonna go
with him like so can you see how he's
like he's speaking with God you know and
the Bible doesn't say like but it was
fake it was a fake conversation with god
like it doesn't no he's apparently I
don't know he's like not this line he's
talking
so those with them uh now this brings us
to the the kind of weird part of the
story it's probably why it is famous if
at all um or at least I should say known
to you
um because Valen gets on his donkey
uh King James calls it his ass which is
why the story is commonly known as
balaam's ass we're just going to roll
with donkey uh kind of awkward in 21st
century I love the King James Bible it's
hilarious at Parts I know I'm immature
like a fifth grader fifth grade boy
um
so he gets on this this donkey and
um he's gonna go you know see the king
an angel of the Lord standing in the way
uh kind of guarding the Ravine or Valley
or whatever he's trying to go on which
is a little bit strange because just
early in the story it was pretty clear
God's like yes you can go but now the
Angel's like no you know so it's I don't
know it's a little weird uh but anyway
now the Angel's there the donkey sees
the angel
but Balaam does not so all he knows is
his donkey isn't moving and so he's
getting more Furious by the minute um
we'll read this little snippet of the
story from numbers 22. I think uh you
know generally when we read the Bible I
think we approach it as this sort of you
know it is it says we should like kind
of a sacred you know spiritual text but
probably always taking it very serious
um I don't think that's really the way
to read it I think the Bible is like
trying to be funny here that's my guess
um because it is a very strange I mean
well I'll read it you'll see uh pick up
the story verse 28 chapter 22 then the
Lord opened the donkey's mouth
and it's said to Balaam
what have I done to you to make you beat
me these three times Balaam answered the
donkey that's right he's gonna have a
conversation with the Donkey
you've made a fool of me if only I had a
sword in my hand I would kill you right
now the donkeys said to bail him am I
not your own donkey
which you've always written to this very
day have I been in the habit of doing
this to you
no he said
ridiculous then the Lord opened balaam's
eyes he saw the angel of the Lord
standing in the road with a sword drawn
he bowed down he fell face down
the angel of the Lord said to Balaam go
with the men but speak only what I tell
you so Balaam went with baloch's
officials now as I hinted earlier it's
the weird parts of the story that kind
of draw all our attention
and we're like this is so bizarre and we
don't really pay attention to like
anything else
you know it's sort of like yep that's
the story balaam's donkey you know just
that's how we remember it
um but actually it's really the honestly
it's the least interesting part of the
story it's the weirdest but it's the
least interesting
um part so we will speak no longer of
balaam's donkey um instead we're gonna
keep moving and really the the kind of
question driving this whole message
tonight is really this why does Balaam
have such a bad reputation in the Bible
that's kind of the question because as I
mentioned earlier you go through Numbers
chapter 22 23 24 balance having
conversations with God he's like okay
Lord whatever you want me to do you want
me to go okay I'll go oh wait you don't
want me to go okay I won't but you want
me to go okay I mean he's just like in
lockstep uh and then honestly it gets
even I mean he once he gets there on
moab's doorstep
um and with the king
um or sorry into the nation of Moab like
honestly his faithfulness to God only
really increases
um he has this whole conversation where
baylock's like okay so I'm gonna give
you money and then you're gonna curse
these people and he's like okay but fair
warning I can only say what God tells me
to say in balak he's like oh right right
you know nudge nudge wink wink of course
we understand each other you know I pay
you money and you only speak what God's
right right of course yes you holy man
you know
um but balaam's like for real
anybody's like I know for real you know
so they proceed now this is what happens
three times he goes up to a high place I
guess that's supposed to be like kind of
gives you spiritual power you could see
he could see the Israelites all encamped
there it goes up three times to Cursed
them
and instead what he says is nothing but
blessing
it's just beautiful I mean honestly some
of the most beautiful poetic remarkable
phrases ever uttered about the people of
God come from this Pagan Prophet Balaam
and he's let me throw out he's like very
apologetic about the whole thing he's
like I'm so sorry about but I mean what
can I do you know when balox of course
Furious and but he's just three times he
just keeps doing it over and over here I
want to give you a little snippet this
is the uh this is chapter 23 verse 8
just to give you a feel for the kind of
things remember he's supposed to curse
them and instead he says this
um how can I curse Those whom God has
not cursed um how can I denounce Those
whom the Lord has not denounced
excuse me now to verse 11 balak said to
Bala what have you done to me I brought
you to curse my enemies you've done
nothing but bless them he answered must
I not speak what the Lord puts in my
mouth okay now for the Poetry this is um
23 verse 5. so here's an example how
beautiful he says how beautiful are your
tents oh Jacob he's supposed to be
cursing them how beautiful are your
tinsel Jacob your Dwelling Places Israel
like valleys they spread out like
Gardens beside a river like aloes
planted by the Lord like theaters in
other words cedar trees beside the
waters
in other words he's saying oh Israel
you're going to be like a peaceful
garden but not a garden in Texas where
you're just like no no like a a garden
by a river you know or a tree again not
in Texas but a tree by a river that's
just soaking up water just flourishing
that's you again he was paid good money
man this is this is what he has to say
now
um
you might ask okay well
maybe in other places in the Bible he's
spoken of poorly this Balaam because he
was so mean to his donkey
uh I maybe but I don't
I don't think so and in fact in the
places where the Bible mentions Balaam
it doesn't you know doesn't really
mention the donkey incident so much uh
here's a this is an example of where
other biblical writers do not like this
Balaam
this problem not at all this is second
Peter chapter 2 verse 15. they talk
about like certain people in the church
they have left the straight way
they've wandered off to follow the way
of Balaam
who loved the wages of wickedness
not exactly a glowing endorsement huh
like they're not a fan uh Peter's not a
fan
or here's another example this is from
The Book of Micah chapter 6 verse 15. my
people remember remember what Baloch
king of Moab plotted and what balaam's
son of bior and third
now based on everything we've read we're
like what do you mean what do you mean
answer you mean all those wonderful
blessings he spoke over the people I
mean what what are they so paranoid
about well here's the here's the thing
um balaam's story does not end in
Numbers Chapter 24. it seems like it
does
um but it does not so here's kind of
what happens
um numbers 24 recounts how Balaam part
sways with baylock
and they are not on good speaking terms
because he's paid all this money to
curse the people and he's nothing but
bless them and talk about aloes planted
by rivers and you know he's so he's
hacked off so
um he leaves
um but then a few months go by and still
the Israelites they're just kind of
encamped there on the doorstep of Moab
and then
um suddenly the moabite women begin to
we'll say meet and greet with the
Israelite men
and then we read this this is chapter
25. while Israel was staying in shatim
the men began to indulge in sexual
immorality with moabite women who
invited them to the sacrifices to their
gods the people ate the sacrificial meal
and bowed down before these Gods so
Israel yoked themselves to the all of
peor that's the god there and the Lord's
anger burned against them
now we find out later in chapter 31 that
this was like a kind of a strategy of
the moabites they did this very much on
purpose
um now who gave them this idea
I'll give you three guesses
but you'll only need one
so
numbers 31 verse 16 says this the
moabites followed who
old Balaam they followed balaam's advice
and enticed the Israelites to be
unfaithful to the Lord
in other words
Balaam was
he was a crafty one
he was he was sneaky all this and I can
only say What God Says I Just Lord what
do you want me to do I'll only do what
you want me to you know if you want me
to go I'll go and
it seems that Balaam I don't know was it
Balaam the man of God Balaam the
spiritual person I don't
some Balaam left
but
it's be upon you
um
but but it seems that Balaam who was he
like Balaam the political consultant
Balaam the advisor Balaam the The Hired
Gun like that Balaam came back and what
it seems they did is he he said look
they lock you're going about this all
wrong I I what am I supposed to I can't
speak curses over people that God wants
to bless I can't do that
so let me this is let me tell you how
you need to get them what you have to do
in a situation like this
is have them bring a curse upon
themselves
That's What She Gotta Do
and this is why Balaam son of bior is
despised throughout the scriptures
now what are we to make of this like
what what might this mean for our lives
I think this is a really rich story
because it's kind of touching on
something we almost never talk about in
church circles
and we might sum it up like this
there is a dark side or a shadow side
to spiritual
an emotional intelligence
or we might even replace the word
intelligence there with like power
um I mean because in essence that's
Balaam right the man he speaks with God
um he's he has a certain spiritual power
uh clearly he understood human beings
well
uh he so he seems to have and he seems
to have some kind of theological train
like he understood Israelite religion at
some level enough that he's like here's
how you do it man in other words this
bail him like he was really smart
he was really smart he he had
theological knowledge he had
psychological knowledge he was
emotionally intelligent he was tuned in
and sneaky
and it seems to me that kind of hiding
in that like
there's some insight there's some lesson
um for us here
um I just out of kind of curiosity after
writing a lot of this and researching
Balaam I Googled
um when emotional intelligence is bad
I don't think I'd ever Googled something
like that before and I found this
article this is from the Atlantic and it
was titled this is a better thing to
search when emotional intelligence goes
wrong a little more poetic
um but here's the the quote this is from
Andrew Giambrone the writer he says
those with high emotional intelligence
do better at work they have fewer health
problems they report Greater Life
satisfaction there's a catch though
other researchers have recently examined
what they call the Dark Side of
emotional intelligence and their
findings suggest an unnerving link
between understanding people
and using them
that's Balaam
he's not an idiot
but he used that knowledge use that
insight
to manipulate
now for those wondering what emotional
intelligence what is that it's basically
a deep deep awareness and understanding
of
your own self what you're thinking why
you're thinking it what you're feeling
why you're feeling it
and what that does is over time
as you grow in that you become very good
at knowing what others are thinking and
feeling
this is what that quote's talking about
so you we tend to only think this is why
I say we don't talk about this very much
because we tend to just emphasize all
the good parts you know like hey we
gotta grow an awareness we gotta
understand who we are we gotta be able
to name what we're feeling like we've
got to learn how to relate to others
into it what they're feeling
you're like come on this is we got to
learn to do this
um
but you can see where there's like a
shadow side to that I remember
um being in in seminary and learning
like reading all sorts of books then
learning about you know Theology and
um
just human beings psychology how a lot
of this works and at first it was just
all good I was this is amazing learning
such good things you know but but
eventually I started to
see this very problem I started to see
like oh oh no
oh no oh like so you can
you can learn you can gain this kind of
knowledge because now you might be
wondering what's the connection between
emotions emotional intelligence in
spiritual
spirituality started the spiritual power
I think the connection is spiritual
disciplines and practices
right we're always encouraging I'm
always encouraging people like prayer
you know Solitude silence
get in touch with what's going on in
here
you know like come to know yourself come
to understand yourself let God meet you
let God speak to you and then let it and
then start to sense what others are
thinking and feeling and be able to show
up for them
like I could see this is what I started
learning in seminary I started to
understand like oh my gosh that is power
right like you start to gain what
happens in other words what happens when
it worked
what happens when we actually start to
gain self-control
like oh quite a bit
and you're not the one losing it in the
arguments anymore
no you're fully in control
can you see where that's like oh like
what this reminding me of is um certain
villains and movies like the worst ones
aren't they always calm
you know what I mean like they're not
like the their Sidekick is sort of the
dummy who's always like ah let's get
them boss ah he's real emotional just
flying off the handle like an idiot you
know what I mean but the villain
oh no
they're thinking thinking thinking
they know the soft spots of their enemy
they know what to say
they can you see how it's creepy isn't
it like in other words it can be really
hard to tell the difference between a
saint and the most evil person you've
ever met
especially at first because you start to
see the fruit the results of their lives
and then it kind of plays out
but at first like it's really hard
because they've both been down the
spiritual path
both face themselves
deep awareness
deep understanding of human beings and
what makes them tick and you either in
other words you either use that for the
good
or oh my God
it's the worst it would have been better
if you never started down the path at
all
you know what I mean like it would it
would have been better not to do it
because what happens is you get tempted
to go the way of Balaam I might sum it
up like this on the far side of
spiritual maturity self-awareness and
emotional intelligence lies ever new
Temptations
the knowledge meant for blessing
can curse
the wisdom meant to heal can destroy
the Insight meant to build others up
can be used to tear them down the
understanding intended to nurture love
can shift towards manipulation
this was balaam's great error using his
spiritual power and intelligence for
great evil
now in closing I want to ask hopefully
something that's a little bit happier a
happier question and that question would
be this
what did Christ do with his power
I mean if you think about it like if we
think Balaam was powerful
you know hearing from God you know the
ability to bless and curse it Christ was
more powerful
Christ to
had all power Christ who he knew more
about he's fully Divine and fully human
he knew more about us in what makes
human beings sick than we could ever
hope to know about ourselves
is Christ who had all power who or has
all power who could have politics and
manipulated his way to the top of any
hierarchy in any domain or sphere
politics
religion
just business I mean just whatever he
could have just climbed that hierarchy
just manipulating and using that power
and I mean I mean if you think of the
temptation of Jesus and in Matthew
chapter four with uh with the devil
tempting him right and that was kind of
that was the offer do you want to go the
way of Balaam
right that was
power Philippians 2 puts it so
beautifully
that he took on the very form of a
servant
and humbling himself he became obedient
to the point of death even death on a
cross
he laid down his life
he didn't go the way of Balaam
he laid down his life he served others
he became
oh
the one who used his knowledge and he
used it for blessing not cursing he used
that wisdom to heal not destroy use that
insight to build others up not tear them
down he used his understanding to
nurture loved rather than shifting
towards manipulation
and so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight
may this be a moment where we just kind
of get settled in our own hearts and
Minds like I don't want to go the way of
Balaam
I want to go the way of Christ if I have
if there is any maturity any spiritual
power or wisdom or Insight or knowledge
or understanding of yourself or others
let's commit Here and Now
to use it for the good
to use it for the way of love to follow
the path of Christ that's that's our
call and that's the invitation tonight
so
this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
in you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
blessed are the ones who do not be
All The Broken Pieces of their heart
blessed all the tears of all the we
[Music]
AK pouring like a sky falling stars
blessed are the wounded ones
brave enough to show the Lord this scars
blessed are the hurts
[Music]
of God
the kingdom is yours
hold on
foreign
[Music]
serving with the guarded gratitude
and blessed are the ones who fight for
just
longing for the coming days
[Music]
hold on a little
this is
[Music]
foreign
kingdom is yours
[Music]
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
this is
[Music]
the kingdom is yours
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
[Music]
thanks so much for being here tonight as
we were saying that last song and
listening to Brett's message I was
reminded that there are those of us in
this room and watching that have been
hurt at the hands of people who have
power
spiritual trauma is a real thing family
trauma is a real thing and if you need
prayer I will be in the back and happy
to pray with you hug you listen to you
whatever you might need and by the same
token there are some of us that have
hurt
uh others and there is forgiveness
there's healing there's processing for
that and I just encourage you in the
coming week
um
to pray to God and ask God where are
there places that I might need to
process a little more maybe reach out
and and you know get some get some help
talk to someone for example at the
centerpiece conference there's going to
be a whole breakout session on spiritual
trauma
when we get this stuff out to out into
the light that's where healing happens
and we want to be that kind of a
community that doesn't back down from
these things that is hopefully a safe
and brave place to process that
hopefully we are
we are hurting people we're not hurting
people at all you know we don't that's
not what we want to do here
um we're human though and so we just
want to be open to places where we need
to grow
and also be a place where people can
come and be healed together and in the
light so
um don't forget about the centerpiece
conference cards are out there grab one
on your way out we have the baptism
classes coming up next month
um also
if this community has blessed you at all
we would be so appreciative if you would
give financially that's how this thing
keeps going it's the fuel for what we do
here for our Outreach for the work that
happens here Among Us in this community
you can do that at the box in the back
or you can give online at
thetabletx.org we would be so grateful
if you would partner with us in that way
lastly I would love to send you out with
a benediction and a blessing over your
week ahead so if you are comfortable
doing so can stand to your feet
foreign
feel free to hold your hands out in a
posture of receiving these words that I
believe are true for each and every one
of you
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
love and compassion and Grace to
everyone you come in contact with this
week be blessed we hope to see you back
here next week good night
[Music]
the kingdom is yours
hold on
hold on and this is not me
[Music]
hope he's in the Lord keep your eyes